l'avenue tu vois c'est l'heure du
premier service à la corde des pâtures
il ya déjà une vingtaine de couverts de
réserver et le mytho nage ça se passe là
dans un bus
recycler en cuisine on s'approvisionne
turbo les légumes chez les maraîchers
qui sont juste derrière qui ne livrent
au jardin des oliviers qui à beaugency
c'est aussi la même personne qui nous
livre au bar les jus de fruits et puis
l'épicerie bio qui est à tavers quand en
fait quand c'est pas locales par exemple
le riz en a pas dans le coin d'un coup
c'est du riz bio comprend à l'épicerie
bio et pour faire tourner les fourneaux
les frigos la cafetière pour le petit
déjeuner
car oui les animateurs de la guinguette
dorment sur place tout l'été
il faut de l'électricité fournie ici par
32 panneaux solaires nous c'était un
élément clé du projet parce qu on est au
milieu de rien donc il fallait
absolument faire venir de l'électricité
est ce qu'on se raccorder sur des
forages des agriculteurs qui sont à un
kilomètre ou alors nous ont trouvé ça
plus sympa pour l'identité et puis pour
affirmer un petit peu notre volonté ce
qu'on voulait faire avec ce lieu et puis
du coup là on part à la recherche d'une
personne qui pourrait nous faire une
étude
regardez un peu ce qu'on pourrait faire
avec le courant de la loire ici la loire
toute proche procure déjà l'eau traitée
avant et après usage pour le nettoyage
et bien sûr il ya les toilettes sèches
l'accessoire écolo indispensable devenu
très tendance
le fait de voir qu'ils respectent la
nature il utilise les énergies
renouvelables qu'ils utilisent l'eau de
la loire qui que l'occ salit la retraite
justement de donc ça c'est intéressant
c'est un puissant va lui ai dit moi
puisque j'ai une réservation tout à
l'heure et
ils veulent savoir ce qu'on mange demain
bien sûr je leur ai dit de la surprise
et de la confiance mais t'as pas une
idée plus précise
j'avais jamais la corne des pâtures sera
rendu à son état naturel en septembre il
vous reste un peu plus d'un mois pour
profiter de cette parenthèse enchantée
au coeur de l'été
[Musique]